Well in the sense that I think we
certainly understand that uh,
we cannot,
uh,
we cannot continue to rely on petroleum
is a major source of energy.
Now there,
there are two dimensions to our
addiction to petroleum.
By the way,
let's start by saying that petroleum is
our largest single source of energy.
About 40% of our energy comes from
petroleum.
This is higher than almost any other
major economic power.
Most of the countries rely on other
sources of energy or a,
a bigger spread,
a greater spectrum of energy.
We are very petroleum dependent and,
and this is partly because we were once
a major petroleum producer.
It was once abundant and cheap.
So,
uh,
it was natural to rely on oil.
But the,
but that ended in 1970 when we became a
net wet.
Well,
when our energy,
domestic energy production peaked and we
started relying on imports.
So we have a problem that we're very
dependent on petroleum.
Now there are two problems with,
with our dependence on petroleum.
One of one is that we have to get it
from,
from foreign countries.
And that ties our foreign policy very
much to uh,
to,
to obtaining more and more oil from
other countries,
many of which are unfriendly or
dangerous or hostile.
And that has led to the militarization
of our foreign energy policy.
I have spoken a little bit about that,
uh,
on one hand and there's a high cost
involved in that.
Also,
there's a very big economic cost in the
sense that we are exporting more and
more dollars to pay for imported oil.
And those dollars that we spend our,
the maybe the,
the largest single factor in our balance
of payments deficit and that's
contributing to the weakening of the US
style or with respect to other
currencies,
which is contributing to the economic
slowdown we're seeing in this country.
So our dependence on foreign oil is a
problem,
you know,
and the other side of the coin or the
other dimension of this is that oil,
like other fossil fuels produces carbon
dioxide.
And insofar as we continue to rely on
petroleum,
we're going to continue to emit carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere and we're
going to have a problem reducing our
greenhouse gas emissions.
So we have a double problem.
Now we want to cut back on carbon
dioxide emissions and we want to cut
back on our reliance on imported
petroleum.
And the only way to do that is to cut
back on our use of petroleum period.
And at this stage in the game,
we really have no plan in place to do
that.
And that's why I say,
uh,
all these efforts,
for energy independence that rely on
domestic sources of petroleum or a
dangerous delusion,
you know,
leading us to think there's a petroleum
solution.
There is no petroleum solution.
There's only non-petroleum sooner.
Ooh,
Shit.